hey guys just really quick want to let
you know this video contains graphic
descriptions of violence involving
firearms
and also when we filmed this episode it
was a while back and we were taking all
the necessary safety precautions
regarding covid at that time this is an
important topic so let us know what you
think in the comments below and thanks
for watching
i know for the rest of my life when i
have kids i'm gonna be
worried that they might experience the
same things that i have
it was about 11 o'clock i was getting
ready to leave the bar
it was just a normal day i walked in
with my friends and i was in my first
period class
i was on the dance floor he
walked in with a gun in hand
and started open fire on the bar just
kind of happened in
the middle of nowhere of course you're
just having fun at a concert
and next thing you know it's massacre
going on all around
bang bang bang bang and i just remember
like yelling at my teacher like we need
to lock the doors right now we're in a
school shooting
i ended up running over the opposite
side of the bar
i didn't know where any of my friends
were it was
chaos somebody has a gun and they have a
motive
and there's not a whole lot you can do
besides try to you know get away
i don't really think much about it i
mean it's just another big corporation
doing
their thing
i believe in the right to protect
yourself to pursue life liberty
and happiness i believe guns are the
great equalizer and unfortunately
sometimes they have to be used
anytime there is a mass shooting it's
always
oh this is the nra's fault in fact the
only time
nra members have been involved in mass
shootings is when we're stopping them
the united states does not have a mass
shooting problem the united states has a
mental health
a ignorance around the second amendment
and
irresponsibility problem you can't look
at it in a vacuum you have to look at
the entire history
and in this country every stage where
liberty was achieved for a group
typically it was a war that was involved
i don't personally know anybody who's a
member of the nra
i'm not sure what they have to say
welcome to the party everybody
i'm antoinette i'm 39 years old i'm a
mom and i help run my
family small business hi i'm hayden i'm
17 and i'm currently a senior in high
school
my name's heather i'm a nra certified
handgun instructor
and i'm just here to have a civil
conversation about guns
my name is john i work in the software
industry and i'm a mass shooting
survivor
i'm dylan 23 years old a two-time mass
shooting survivor
i'm taylor i'm 20 years old i was at the
borderline bar and girl shooting
and i work with old people homage i'm
the founder of black guns matter
reform scumbag just trying to do the
right thing to defend
the natural rights to protect life i'm
jai
i'm 37 years old i'm an abolitionist i
make my money as a criminal defense
attorney
can i get my nra members on the left
uh yeah so four months ago was my school
shooting november 14th today is actually
the four month anniversary i didn't know
the two people
um who the shooter shot but i did know
the um
shooter so i did in a sense have a
connection to someone who died because
he did commit suicide
after killing two and i believe he's
injuring three so
it's just crazy to have to go through
that i had a cousin
who died ultimately of a shotgun it was
an accident his girlfriend accidentally
shot him in the face with a shotgun
yeah and he lived for three or four
months after that
in complete agony and pain i was yeah a
little kid so i mean that was really
kind of the first i
had heard about something like that
right and then you know of course with
the mass shooting
you know i didn't know the people
personally but i've heard a number of
stories they all sound like great people
my most recent was last week eighth a
classmate of mine
he got killed by the la sheriffs and
then at
his memorial service i ran into
my other buddy martin who just got
killed he was in the barbershop somebody
ran in
shot him last week and i've had those
experiences
just constantly pretty much since the
high school age
during the shooting i was at one of my
best friends he was like my brother his
name was cody kaufman
i pulled him out on the dance floor and
we were dancing we're having so much fun
because he
just got new jeans that were like two
sizes too tight
and i just got new boots and next thing
you know
you do one more line dance and it's all
over
i was at the vegas shooting
at the concert and then borderline as
well i had
lost one person in vegas that i had
tried to help
and then at borderline i had lost eight
people that i knew
oh sorry i'm not trying to cry but yeah
most of the people not even just the
people here i think most of the people
that's
going to be watching you may know
someone that has experienced that and i
think that the key
to to solving that is finding out where
that comes from if that person took life
and then wound up taking their own life
it's pain there i think in my
neighborhood we just get so numb to it
i just want to say i'm so sorry for
everyone here i can't imagine going
through it and
i have a question for you so you're in
high school
yeah do you feel safer
or less safe being that your whole
school is a
gun-free zone i guess i feel safer
but i think at the end of the day it
doesn't matter if it's a gun or if it's
a knife or it's a bomb or if it's a
car running into people i think he was
going to do it no matter what
do you wish that there were there was
more that you'd be able to have done
it must feel helpless it was like i went
fight or flight so my thing was like i
want to fight
i tried to do everything that i possibly
could with the situation that i was in
to be able to help it may not have been
the people in the quad
but it was the people in my class so my
first thing was how do i
make them feel safe so it was
like unplugging a computer cart putting
it up against the door stacking desks in
front of the door making sure that
people couldn't get in
and i was watching like the news on my
phone and you know i'm not gonna tell
them that like these people are dead
or um or these people are injured
because that's just to make it worse
i think that mass shootings are a
problem but i think that a lot of the
time we're focusing on the wrong thing
when it comes to mass shootings
it is a double-edged sword we should
focus on some sort of
gun regulation but at the same time the
other side of the sword is it's a lot of
mental health
i think mental health is our problem in
the united states because we don't focus
on it enough
it seems like the other side tries to
push
like as if you don't care and i think we
care very very much
people think that you know people who
own guns just want to shoot things
i mean personally i'd be terrified if i
ever had to use it in self-defense and
that's why the responsibility that comes
with training is incredibly important
absolutely i'm a gun owner i think one
of the
proudest things i feel is when i teach
especially women
and they send me a picture and they're
like guess what i just bought today
and i just feel like i've helped someone
become safer in their life for me it
goes back
like you know in karate class as a kid
they teach you
before everything is like this is for
defense i'm not
getting this to go out and use it to
harm people i'm
i'm getting it for that safety and
that's what it
boils down to for me is knowing that
it's going to be
a battle you may win but it's at least
going to be a battle
it's not if you even if you just take
the safety part out just shooting is fun
in general like going to their range is
a fun time so they're used for
recreation
and like also hunting so many people
that's the reason they buy guns is for
hunting to provide
food i it's almost like my equalizer
so like it it helps you and it gives you
more peace of mind like
i am not as vulnerable and unsafe as
people think
people who don't know why i've shot
plenty
and i've been trained with you know how
to use a firearm the reason i don't have
one is simply i think because of that
accident factor
you know is this thing going to be
locked up and safe
at all times you know what i mean just
to avoid some sort of disaster i think
all the reasons that you guys are
stating that you do have one is
completely legitimate and i've certainly
considered
you know potentially purchasing one and
you know doing it the right way
obviously and all those good things but
yeah i think that that's potentially
just why i haven't gone there yet
i'm not against owning a gun eventually
i will i believe in the second amendment
my dad trained me from time to time he
show i know where the guns are in the
house i know how to use them
i've gone shooting with my friends a
handful of times like
i'm around it i'm a part of it like i
mean for me it's really no big deal it's
just my own upbringing like i just
haven't gotten to that point of taking
the action into going to get the gun
myself my dad was
raised in upstate new york so he was
around guns all the time
and we've talked about it but it wasn't
for like protection more it was more for
like that was your lifestyle right it's
like you needed to go out and
shoot a couple bunnies you needed to go
out and shoot like a deer that was like
how you fed yourself that's how you
lived and so i think if i was in that
situation definitely i would own a gun
but
in a situation where it's like where i
live i feel safe now here's the thing
i can disagree with you and i do however
i am never and anyone that tries to
tries to make you feel different than
that viewpoint
i'm never gonna do that that's your your
right to not have one i'm like cool
when i go to my friend's houses that are
afraid of guns that i've known for 15
years
i make a personal choice i don't take my
gun in a house
i make a joke about it and i'm like hey
man if somebody kills me in your house
i'ma kill you
you know what i'm saying but just just
commending and making sure that if
that's your personal choice
and your personal freedom and your
personal liberty don't let
nobody talk you out of that i don't
think about whether we need more or less
guns in this country i think about
freedom
if you my brother and you my or you my
sister and you don't want a gun i
respect your right to not have one
if you my brother or my sister and you
want more guns i respect your right to
have one
what you lose me is if you use any of
those firearms negligently
or to rob or rape or kill unjustifiably
then i don't really give a [ __ ] what
happens to you
america has a mass shooting problem
yeah a mass shooting is different than
let's say a murder when you think about
a mass shooting the perpetrator they're
usually suicidal
right and they have no agenda other than
to take lives and that's quite
different than a typical crime that
would involve a firearm
and it's a phenomenon i think that's
where i'm
i'm somewhat pushing that back i think
in order for us to solve it we have to
start looking at it
this is massive amounts of people that
are still shooting
humans even if it's themselves right if
we're talking about stats
mass shootings they would say are not a
problem based on the data of what that
definition of mass shooting is
because that's less than one percent of
all death
in the country in regards to firearms so
if
if i went just with that i would not
agree that there's a mass shooting
problem
but how can i sit next to this young man
here who lost eight out of 12 people
that he knew in one
juncture and say that's not a problem
when we have a mass shooting problem we
also have a mental health problem right
my age range from i believe it's
15 to 25 we have the highest depression
rate in the entire history of the human
race
what that data can improve it was the
kid's birthday the day that he shot up
the school
if one person said happy birthday got
him a card talk to him and say like hey
i know it's your birthday next week want
to do something this weekend
it's all about how are we making these
authentic human connections with people
if we just talk to people i think that's
where that's where our problem is
i think you oh well i gotta wait today
i believe we have a mental health
problem believe we have a drug problem i
believe we have a racial problem
and the reason why i don't think mass
shooting is a problem is because
if we took all the guns it wouldn't stop
the violence
like you pointed out they could have
used a car they could have used a knife
they could use a bomb
that would not absolve these deaths
uh us from experiencing these things
because they find another way
and by calling it mass shooting and
saying
we need this gun control now that's from
my perspective
just more of an opportunity to make
another law that the police can lock up
people in my specific demographic for i
think it's also important to know
that i think it's something like 8.9 out
of 10 mass shootings happen in gun-free
zones
so in my mind if someone's going to
commit
mass shootings and there's a sign that
says there's no guns here there will be
no bullets flying back
at you versus there are trained people
ready to do
whatever they have to do to protect life
here which
place are they going to go like i
couldn't believe the
um in nice france on bastille day there
was like 86 people mowed down by a
guy with a truck but you don't hear
anything about
we need truck reform or like truck
violence it's always
gun violence and you don't ever hear
that term specifically with
other weapons i guess you could say
i guess one thing that i think viewers
should take away from
my experience is people go through
crisis
but you should never give up on what you
believe in
and you should always push through it do
you think that
the united states
yes yes i do believe that there is
definitely an issue
that needs to be addressed and resolved
any mass casualty
is terrible i think if you look in inner
cities like chicago
and baltimore the media is nowhere
around and there's a mass shooting
almost every weekend so i think it's
interesting to look at exactly why they
pick
the mass shootings that they pick to
just delve into in the media
it should be harder to purchase a gun
so if you agree it's like speaking of
truth brother
there's something called the uh gun show
loophole
think about it like the black market
right unless you have a storefront
and you're telling you know the
government hey i want to sell guns and
make a profit
you need to be certified in that sense
if you're going to be doing that
otherwise it's
completely legal to you know give a gun
to a friend
or what have you so i think that it
creates an entire underbelly of the
market
that really shouldn't exist i mean you
know if we're not keeping track of who
has a gun and
where they're buying it who's selling it
i think guns get in the wrong people's
hands
i believe when the reports of the
investigation came out of my school
shooting it was a
kick gun so he had actually like put it
together himself he also grew up in a
family
that um that supported guns his dad i
think was a bullet maker
i think people are gonna get guns no
matter what like if they want a gun
they're gonna get a gun
so it definitely is different from state
to state
in california it's very difficult in
illinois it's difficult
and the crazy thing is you see a lot of
gun violence
in those states but new hampshire it's a
constitutional carry state meaning that
you don't even have to have a permit you
can conceal carry
and they have virtually no homicides
with guns so
i'm just curious you what you're asking
for basically
is like a national registry for firearms
right
if we could do that why not okay so i
feel like if you look back in history
it's never worked out for citizens if
you look back at germany
if you look at venezuela right now fair
points and i read somewhere that
uh you know if you have a controlled
substance
possession charge in the last year you
can't get a gun
if you have had a misdemeanor sentenced
to over two years in prison you can't
have a gun
and these are these are great safeguards
they need to just be
imposed more i think it should be easier
it's the only constitutional right that
you lose with a conviction
like you come out of prison you still
have freedom of speech but now you can
no longer
protect yourself now i understand people
can
do stuff to relieve themselves even of
the right to life
i believe that you can give up your
right to life based on your actions
but i think we make it too easy to give
up those rights and then when you add in
the racial component to these laws
that makes me even more of an advocate
against
these kind of gun restrictions my
opinion of firearms is that's the only
thing that really led to abolition was
when black people
picked up guns it's really hard to
enslave people who
have firearms and so based on the
history
of this land my people in this land i
think
every one of us should have a firearm be
trained and
become proficient and learn how to use
it
teachers should be armed
i mean i believe teachers that want to
be armed should be armed i don't think
anybody should have
to you know worry about the
responsibilities that are associated
with gun ownership if they don't want to
i don't think it's right for everybody
but obviously the more good people with
guns especially in a school
i think that would be great look at what
we do protect with firearms you know our
politicians our celebrities
and for our kids we protect them with
gun-free zones and they're just left
sitting ducks right so i think like if
you have concealed carry permit holders
if you have maybe veterans or ex-law
enforcement that are teachers
would you not want them to be able to
protect your kid if
otherwise your option is you're not
protected you have to wait
10 20 minutes for the police to come
with their firearms to come
rescue your kids so i think that if you
want to and you are willing to go
through similar training almost like a
concealed carry
so you know what you're doing and it's
not just handing a gun to some random
teacher saying here protect your kids
it's more more so like you have the
training for it you have the background
check like they said like
you almost are prepared in a way
to do what is right
i don't think that a teacher can take a
take the life of one of their students
that's a good point
like like if you think you know mrs
stewart my 10th grade english teacher is
going to be able to
shoot one of her 16 year old kids as a
gun i don't see that and to that point
the inner city and urban areas and
things like that the teacher-student
relationship
is not great i've seen uh you know
videos on youtube
teachers getting beat up and stuff yeah
right so do we want them to have
firearms
we all have jobs right and we all have
our roles within our jobs that we have
to do
that we know like this is what we're
doing for today
every day something may change where we
have to adjust to it and all that stuff
the teachers have their job where it's
to
teach these kids through their process
of growing up but now
i have these sixth grade kids where
there's 25 of them
i have to put myself at the point of
this moment if the shooter comes to us
it's between them me and the kids now if
something were to happen to me
these kids have nothing i think with the
precautions that we take already with
the schools into learning how to close
your blinds lock your doors do all that
stuff get to the back corners be quiet
that is a good precaution because these
kids
when they're going to school they're
going to learn have fun be with their
friends
this teacher now has a weapon on them
who's also to say that the teacher can't
take action
i know for the rest of my life when i
have kids i'm gonna
be worried that they might experience
the same things that i have
but i have to accept that if i do i
don't have control of everything
myself and the other individuals that
are the survivors of
these mass shootings were not the voice
for everyone's
own beliefs of what they have gone
through
everyone deals with it in their own way
but we
are sharing our experiences with you
guys and hopefully that
brings some light into obviously what
goes on with
it you know i try to not politicize it
if you think about it from a practical
level certain people shouldn't have guns
right how do we how do we identify those
people and how do we
stick to the system make sure that it's
all backed up and safe
you know i don't think that we should do
away with the second amendment but do i
think that there's a you know
a lot of bad people out there i do and
should they you know have such easy
access to a firearm i think not
i think that no
mentally or physically sane person would
commit a hate crime so big
if there wasn't some underlying issue if
we
find a way to talk about that and help
that that there's
really going to be no problem at all a
lot of the stigma around
us surrounding mass shootings is guns
but i it's
it's really the person and i think if
we're all more kind we just we end up
feeling better right
well for more loving we create more
understanding around everybody
regardless of
race religion gender identity any of
that stuff um if we're more empathetic
we again we cultivate more understanding
around who you are and then there's less
hatred because i understand what
where you're coming from and if we're
more vulnerable then we're able to talk
about things like mental health
we're able to talk about like hey i feel
depressed hey i'm anxious
hey you know i've been thinking about it
i want to shoot up a school i'm
like and you're the only person i feel
safe talking to you know if we
prioritize those we as humans become
better
and then we can contribute to our global
community that's i mean i love all that
i'm being a mom especially i want my
daughter to grow up in that kind of
world you know and
i think that those things are totally
possible i just think that also in the
meantime we have to address the issue
that there is evil in this world like
we don't want it to exist i don't think
you can legislate it out a good guy with
a gun is going to stop a bad guy
hopefully with a gun that's like i mean
the best chance you know
trust me i really want to believe that
and i do that there is greatness in this
world there's kind people that we can
do a lot of great things i've just seen
too much now where
it only really comes down to one
individual
has the mindset that this is what i
choose to do today
and they take those actions that's how
the cards are played
i want there to be something that can be
done to stop and prevent
all these things to happen so that these
three
and you guys don't have to experience it
one more time or you guys ever in your
life to understand
the shoes that we're in you know there's
almost no rhyme or reason sometimes why
these things happen
and i think that's why it's a problem
i'd love to wave a magic wand and make
make it so that never happens again it's
not possible there's no motive that
makes sense to go to a bar
and and do what the guy did that night
right america
has a sickness america's main sickness
is white supremacy
it's an issue that we have not addressed
it's an issue that's written into the
foundation of this nation
when the founding fathers wrote all men
are created equal
while holding slaves and i think most of
these
issues are rooted in that and if we just
keep you know putting a band-aid on it
and don't get out and get that cancer
we can't reach those levels but i think
that's what it would take
because that's what can start the
healing process
[Laughter]
like this to just be able to sit down
and just be like we got all these